how does it feel to once again be back
in St Louis playing in this prestigious
event no it's always great to be here I
hope to be invited in the near future as
well
um and I'll do my best that's all I can
say uh very well I mean I'm the first
time here in general
and first time I see the chess club I'm
very happy to have this opportunity to
play in this tournament heard too much
about of course all these events and
it's always very beautiful to be a part
of it always when I come
to St Louis it's a
great very nervous yeah this is probably
the most important Tournament of the
year
uh nervous and excited at the same time
it feels incredible it's my first time
in Saint Louis and I felt fantastic
running qualified to be here and I was
really looking forward and I'm happy to
be here always awesome to get back to
Saint Louis it feels like a second home
for many years and uh well
aspirations are always flying high and
we'll see what's going on it's always
great coming back here it's a tournament
that I look forward to all year long
and I hope that I can show some good
form here oh it's fantastic I mean this
is the mecca of chess the place to be
and you you get such a warm welcome here
it's the best place to be for chess well
I was here three years ago before the
pandemic it was a lot of fun I haven't
played in a nice round robin tournament
in ages before that so it's always a
nice opportunity to play as you prepare
for the games
I mostly coach now so this is a great
opportunity to try there
play and feel how it is for my students
and I actually
a couple of my former students actually
playing in the in the journey event here
so um I'll be watching how they're doing
and I'm going to enjoy it wonderful I
feel we feel great to be here yeah I've
been playing here a few times and U.S
Championship long time ago 12 years ago
I played on the tournament four years
ago it was always great it's a great
place to be and also it's wonderful to
see my old friends I've seen some of
them from long ago long ago
[Music]
foreign